Let's face it, job hunting is, well, kind of terrible.
There are so many things to look for in a potential employer...
...but perhaps the most important is pay and benefits.
Hey guys, I'm Andrew Dymburt for Buzz 60,...
...and here are the top companies for compensation and benefits.
The list was compiled by glassdoor.com,...
...a job review site that used feedback from employees over the past year...
...who rated their satisfaction with salary and bennies on a five-point scale.
Coming in at number 25 is eBay.
"Good company, great job security," reads the description,...
...and pharmaceutical company Pfizer ranked 20th on the list...
...as they not only provide great benefits,...
...but also give employees a gym, clinic, cafeteria and a day care.
There are a couple of cell phone carriers that made the list, too:...
...T-Mobile at 17 and Verizon at 15.
Highlighting the top five are a few familiar faces.